[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 des invités on passe
au titre parole à pierre cojan président
de la fédération française du bâtiment
des yvelines en vue des élections
législatives la fédération a décidé de
se faire entendre en avançant 112
proposition alors qu'annie sera
également un débat avec des candidats
dans le département dans les prochains
jours et puis nous recevons nicolas
nédélec coréalisateur de la websérie
ulysse une production réalisée dans les
10 minutes par des bénévoles passionnés
depuis sa sortie en 2013 elle a déjà
obtenu six distinctions dans des
festivals là les élections législatives
approchent
elles auront lieu les 11 et 18 juin
prochains en vue de cette échéance des
groupes de travail de la fédération
française du bâtiment des yvelines se
sont tenues tout au long de l'année ils
ont permis de faire émerger 112
propositions couvrant l'ensemble des
champs législatif pour en discuter nous
recevrons pierre cojan président de la
fédération française du bâtiment des
yvelines bonsoir bonsoir
alors ces douze propositions pourquoi
ces 112 position c était un long travail
de notre fédération nationale s'était
d'abord dans les départements on a
remonté nationale et maintenant nous
allons proposer sans notre opposition
avec 15 orientation halle aux différents
élus futurs élus ou candidats des
initiatives alors sur le territoire ça
concerne quelle ville qu'il ya quoi
comme spécificité
alors nous nous trouvons la légende ou
de propositions sont impartis en 15
priorité ça va de la d'accessibilité de
l'apprentissage
donc c'est tout un énorme échantillons
et nous avons pour cela a prévu une
réunion demain en fin de journée dans
les locaux de l'école cfm de trappes
l'école de notes du bâtiment mais
maintenant c'est là que le meilleur est
pas mieux pour recevoir nos candidats
c'est sûr vous avez parlé de
l'apprentissage
et puis il ya quoi comme autre thème
dans ses 112 propositions pour vraiment
que les gens il ya d'une part le métier
du bâtiment de demain parce que tous
touchants vont c'est que si on change
pas on meurt donc on fait tout pour
s'adapter et on veut essayer de faire
entendre nos positions anneau de nos
candidats c'est à dire on a là l'ex
l'accessibilité des gens on a on a en a
tué on a là les travers des tests est
très attaché il ya l'accession à la pro
a après la propriété
pour donner donner la possibilité aux
gens à l'accession il ya les assurances
la consommation la construction et
d'urbanisme les dialogue social épargne
salariale
on a aussi ne te on se bat aussi pour
supprimer neuf secondes de pénibilité
que qu'on traîne depuis des mois des
années on pense que faire entendre cela
à nos candidats et alors c'est la
première fois que vous faites c'est 112
proposition risque si c'était un travail
donc c'est là c'est que ça va mal ça va
pas comme vous
il ya eu on a ressenti une légère
amélioration en début d'année mais c'est
pas ça est une des petites entreprises
autour on a pas on en ressort pas accord
dans tout ce qu'on souhaite c'est que
l'on soit entendue et fifa 12 position
avec les quinze orientation ce qu'on
veut c'est que ce soit est prise en
compte et que dans les cinq prochaines
années ont négocié notre pari on conçoit
attendus dont on fera en sorte d'être
entendu alors durant ces réunions
comment ça va se passer vous aller
exposer vos soirées voir ce qu'on va
avoir
on va avoir on a déjà les candidats de
2,2
différentes organisations vie politique
françois descend de descamps crosnier
qui est là qui va du parti solistes on à
madame yasmine belmadi du front national
monsieur pascal thévenot du des
républicains monsieur aziz françois
n'diaye de haut marche là et on aura on
est parti ils ont tous répondu présent
titre perdu prison on en a d'autres mais
soit et les premiers et on aura le thème
c'est de faire trois questions ils ont
trois questions qu'on va reposer à
chacun ils ont trois mille pour répondre
d'accord la question en lien avec eelv
aux ivoiriens ils vont avoir un lien
avec la banane à des besoins
d'aujourd'hui la l'on retrouve on
parlait tout à l'heure de la lettre de
l'accessibilité c'est une chose
lalala le dialogue social c'est soi est
une autre on a des environnements
qui est une autre aussi et puis on a
aussi ce qu'on voulait c'est surtout
depuis que je parlais tout à l'heure
c'était de pouvoir
l'accessibilité l'accès au logement
privatif
parce que les gens ont du mal maintenant
moi je ressentais la clientèle faire du
location privée on n'ose pas force de
protéger les locations on n'arrive plus
avoir de logement avoir avoir alloué
alors le but c'est vraiment de lui faire
entendre qui fait fisc allemand séparé
la fiscalité change tous les trois
quatre mois ça c'est bien il faut il
faut qu'on compare sur l'autre alors re
dit non le rendez vous ces grands rendez
vous le rendez vous c'est demain soir à
18 heures au cfai bleus trappe à 2 10 au
13 rue denis papin et on attend tous nos
candidats et on souhaite le bienvenu et
bien le rendez vous est pris
on veut faire de cette page vous
connaissez la websérie ulysse au pas du
tout non non j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
discuter de minutes avec
on va concerner entièrement réalisés
dans les yvelines par des bénévoles
passionnés la web série séduit depuis sa
sortie en 2013 à la déjà obtenu six des
six distinctions dans des festivals
je vous propose de regarder
[Musique]
je m'appelle ulysse et je suis spéciale
tellement spécial que pendant un temps
j'ai cru être quelqu'un d'important un
être unique un héros
un héros
et pour en discuter ce soir nous
recevons ricola nédélec coréalisateur de
la websérie ulysse bonsoir bonsoir
alors c'est créer dans les yvelines mais
dites moi comment vous est venue cette
idée parce qu'il ya véritablement un
vrai scénario je me suis laissé
entraîner en voyant ça tout à l'heure
merci oui un vrai c'est les deux sont
liés en fait on voulait vraiment créer
quelque chose de compliqué avec une
trame narrative assez assez lourde même
plusieurs trames narratives vraiment
faim comme dans les séries qu'on peut
admirer à la c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre et voilà on a on vous l'a
pour reproduire ça donc on long métrage
c'est quelque chose qui est trop long et
trop coûteux pour doit faire le court
métrage avec les crocs coordination et
du coup on s'est intéressé au format web
série gta s'adapter parce qu'on pouvait
travailler façon autres produits sont à
dire pour voilà c'est librement a qu'un
diffuseur immédiat de compter sur
youtube dont pouvoir aller rapidement
médecin olinga voir les rotors aussi des
gens et donc l'idée vraiment l'histoire
elle est venue annoncée de cette envie
de raconter une grande histoire et on
fait un petit pitch parce
qu'effectivement en regardant le petit
trailer du début on voit un jeune homme
qui qui se posaient la question est ce
qu'il est ce que c'est un héros ou pas
alors ce que mon pitch un bon peut-être
que le vote sera mieux parce que c'est
compliqué les pitchs ils vont agir est
incomplet et dites moi en le pitch on
suit les naquit une orpheline dans le
futur en 2038 qui après une 3ème guerre
mondiale donc elle vit dans un
orphelinat
elle reçoit un jour un carnet envoyé par
on ne sait qui sait où elle va commencer
à lire ce carnet et ce carnet raconte
l'histoire de bliss qui se passe avant
la guerre est donc ce personnage lisse
un pouvoir particulier il est immortel
mais sa lampe est parce que lui il va là
il sait pas d'où il vient
il sait pas qui il est il à deux soucis
à faire sauf qu'il ya des méchants qui
vont vouloir à son pouvoir est en fait
elena qui disent cardell à comprendre
que ce pouvoir plus c'est méchant plus
les gens autour de lui vont arriver dans
sa bière et de m'en donner à cet égard
et du coup elle comprend comment bien la
guerre qui allait de où elle vient qui
sont ses parents par exemple quel lien à
la rectrice et qu'elle roule alors à
jouer dans le futur pour peut-être
déjouer le passé vous donner envie
et beaucoup de gens vous suivent j'ai vu
des vidéos avec plus de 9000 vue etc
quand vous avez commencé cette websérie
vous attendiez à ses retours quand on a
commencé déjà on a commencé les gens
qu'on les a on a casté les acteurs et
techniciens latvala on sait pas où on va
il y aura sûrement jamais de bénéfices
suffisants pour vous pour vous payer
mais voilà on veut faire un produit de
qualité qui donnent envie on va
s'appliquer pour faire bien on ira
jusqu'au bout on a une histoire on a une
fin l'aspect important et nous au début
on pensait arriver à fait si on dit m
si on fait mille vue on sera content et
en fait on a un bouche à oreille le
bouche à oreille on a on a fait un peu
de com avant de commencer avant de
diffuser qu'on avait d'épisodes vraiment
tourner assemblée on savait courant
partez on a commencé à faire un peu de
com et on a eu la chance d'avoir la
durée meilleurs fans l'aise qui existe
parce qu'on a des gens qui nous fuit
depuis quatre ans qui nous supportent et
que vous le terme web qui ne nous
risquent donc on a vraiment la meilleure
fin du monde pour ça et ils sont
toujours là et c'est ce qui fait que le
en fait tu parles beaucoup de nous ils
nous ont fait très peu de com au final
par rapport à ce que peuvent peuvent
faire prendre
alors j'ai une question pour que ce
choix des yvelines pour une troisième
guerre mondiale
c'est un peu bizarre dans le mondial
donc bon ouais c'est pas liée à la
guerre non c'est dit c'est pas la libye
est un peu logistique c'est que moi
j'habite m sur versailles jeu 16 pour ça
même la photo j aimerais nous parce que
non il est pas posé la question quoi la
vierge à fait non par les événements
n'ont rien n'a rien à voir à part que
c'est une tc une très belle région et
c'est une très belle ville versailles la
rumba ou ton habitude tous plus ou moins
sûr vers sa destination wallon pouvez
tous se retrouvent facilement et
rapidement mais voilà on voulait
vraiment faire tourner façon à ses
livres avec du petit matériel donc y
avait un point de vue logistique est
évident et puis un point de vue c'est
que la ville est magnifique et on a pu
tourner avec la mêlée dans des lieux
différents assez rapidement il est
toujours en arrêt devant avec la mairie
s'inquiète est génial c'est que la
langue vraie écoute en fait
ils ont vu ce qu'on faisait je ne
pouvais pas avoir déployé des classiques
de location de décor il dit voilà on
fait ça en petit comité rapidement sans
déranger les gens et qui ont fait cela
dans la bonne entente avec la mairie et
puis les commerçants et la ville et et
le succès est au rendez-vous si
distinction oui vous proposer à chaque
fois des festivals ou des pétitions où
on vient carrément vous cherche pas en
fait ça non pas parce qu'on a on
aimerait bien non
alors on aimerait bien mais un seul
d'entre eux n'a pas le problème du lit
ce qu'il faut si ces particularités
c'est qu'on est très long on est sur du
25 minutes compte n'y est pas totalement
le la websérie de base ce n'est même pas
web du tout en fait ben ouais bon n'est
plus au tus 7 13 minutes maximum parce
que c'est il ya un temps de vie très
court sur facebook sur youtube par là et
nous on vote on a commencé sur du 10
minutes pour que les gens adhèrent on va
dire au début et à prendre une s'étend
du 13 17 et 25 minutes met donc les
c'est pour ça que la série marche c'est
qu'on a on a commencé vraiment doucement
et après on a pu avoir un besoin qu'on a
moins de monde qu'une série classique
mondiale super beau fils voilà mais des
gens plus accroché et pour finir
rapidement c'est quoi la suite la suite
on a fini la saison 2 donc là si vous
allez voir vous avez 8h30 de contenu à
découvrir
on écrit la saison 3 qu'on va tourner le
logiquement cette année pour une
diffusion 2018 l'année prochaine eh bien
je remercie puis je vous souhaite bonne
chance pour la suite
merci c'est la fin de ce set 8 les
invités merci de nous avoir suivis et
surtout bonne soirée
[Musique]